alec baldwin insisted he didn't pull the
trigger on the movie set rust instead
the media is out to get him watch
the people that are talking loudest
about what happened or speculating about
what happened we're not on the set of
the film the la times the hollywood
reporter they talk on and on and on
about what if this and what if that uh
the thing that they have in common is
nobody was there
this week the fbi rejected baldwin's
claim that he didn't pull the trigger
now judge what we know is that the actor
saying he's waiting for pending a
sheriff report to determine if the
district attorney will bring charges
against him do you think that there'll
be charges brought against alex baldwin
i don't know but i i remember speaking
to the d.a some time ago and she
obviously is waiting for the sheriff's
report i think it's interesting that
you've got the medical examiner who
ruled that this was a tragic accident um
you know that is a conclusion uh that is
something that is subjective um i think
the most the most disturbing part of all
of this is that the fbi said that the
revolver was in good working order and
that uh in order for that projectile to
come out baldwin had to have pulled the
trigger
that contradicts exactly
a prior statement that that baldwin had
made saying he never pulled the trigger
so the trigger had to be pulled to
release that i think it was a 45 colt um
and and then he he comes up with some
defense his attorney said with the gun
was broken well the gun was broken why
did it work
um and then
and then the second thing that that is a
concern so you've got the criminal issue
and i'll be very quickly about the civil
issue he's at war with uh uh hannah the
uh the armorer because she said that she
had requested specific cross-draw
training so that she would be able to
teach him when he was doing the cross
draw for the shootout and in addition to
that he says baldwin says it was occult
until he was told it was a cold gun so
there's a civil lawsuits up the gazoo
but criminally i don't know maybe
reckless maybe negligent
uh dana i mean to the to that point i
mean he pulled the trigger well that's
the thing about well i'm also curious
about how what a good zoo is that we
could i've always wondered how how far
up the kazoo well one you can believe
and the other one
but i
um this is what i've always felt
if he actually did not pull the trigger
he would have immediately said at the
moment that she was shot that i didn't
even i didn't even pull the trigger he
didn't say that until six weeks later so
i don't believe him
correct oh i uh i think uh that it is uh
i think it's he's he's on the hook for
everything because he's the producer so
i think the armor was incompetent yes
and she was hired for reasons other than
her competence or excellence yes this is
why they needed somebody like an nra
instructor there but they've been
demonizing the nra forever so they went
with some lady with blue hair and 35
tattoos
who did yeah she was a legacy um i look
we know he didn't mean to kill the
person we know that yeah so but the
thing is he's going to be on the hook
for and he's got to pay a lot of money
to that family that there's a young boy
without a mother
joey your take i mean you know your way
around a gun greg made the exact point
this isn't intentional this isn't murder
one this is negligence to the umpteenth
level this is irresponsibility to the up
teeth level this is from the top down
inability to do the most basic things
necessary to have firearms on set and be
safe you don't have to own a bazillion
guns like i did before my boating
accident
to um and some of you will understand
that some of you won't
to understand how a gun works especially
a revolver it's singular double action
it's it's very simple
and if it's double action that means as
he pulled the trigger back he saw the
hammer come back and go back forward of
it single action as he pulled it back he
saw the hammer sling forward so there
were physical characteristics of the gun
if you have the simplest understanding
could have prevented this he's
responsible for not understanding the
tool in his hand he's responsible for
being a boss and having hired people
that didn't do it right and people died
or someone died it's tragic but
responsibility's still there it's steve
responsibility joey guess what we have
to pull the trigger on the segment
because one more thing is up next hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now